autumns I'm certainly curious to see you
know whatever you create and do next you
just seem to keep staying busy and I
think everything comes out of that it's
like yeah you know if you just stay busy
things will happen things you know get
created and you know you get to do fun
stuff and it's exciting you know yeah
that's [ __ ] them again isn't it yeah
they're love fighter and the kid who's
in there I don't know
you should just bust in there after we
load it up yeah then I can be able to
hear us for now I wanna do this you
waste of yelling yes that's the oh you
guys up there
we're good here you over here pain 1,400
a month
shut the front door fighter in the kid
they're both gonna get their ass kicked
one more word out of you and I'm gonna
come over there and AMRO your ass all
right
it's Ray Liotta you [ __ ] that ain't Will
Sasso that big [ __ ] Flintstone have
you guys ever thought of self proofing
this is unprofessional
you [ __ ] kratom junkies lay off the
crate on you crates those guys are
always hopped up on all types of like
rare uppers and snow G&C yeah
oh I hope that's a G and C and venison
what's his name was out there for it
before it opened dude Natalie that's huh
Kalen both up it was shall but that's
weird you don't have a B and C before
Jesus I mean I can understand a
McDonald's for you know you're waiting
for breakfast but that's weird
who is it
[Laughter]
they're telling us you were at the GNC
before it open one day I've been farting
yeah you got less farts in here it's not
gorgeous
who's your guest come over after man
dude half this [ __ ] is your old [ __ ] do
you guys think you should do something
about the sound thing you get your [ __ ]
together you own another cubicle bro
Ryan sardonic really Bryce I look like
your stepdad dude get your [ __ ] life
together dude shap no you startled a
Croatian bro you got a [ __ ] tighten
up dude why the third-world row you look
third-world successful though you don't
have to say no you look okay but the no
you look fine it's the rest to you
though this [ __ ] is on bro
you tell [ __ ] D'Elia if he wants to
strap to come and [ __ ] get this [ __ ]
dude yes the [ __ ] belt you piece of
[ __ ] and it only costs one hundred
eighty two dollars you cheap [ __ ] dude
the [ __ ] is this huh that's a real knife
knife yeah it's and come and get those
wooden shoes some God made for you one
time
those are made of solid wood dude
the others are warm living in one of
them oh yeah get your [ __ ] together dude
know that oh the guy is asthma I'm a
premature baby
that dude's a premature baby dude seven
months and look what he's doing
probably I have a good body one more
strong flex I'm just gonna break his own
back dude
oh my bad guys get a [ __ ] guess huh
get a gasps Bravo Wow
back off the kratom back off the kratom
u8u hey your shirt bro dude that shirt
came with school supplies get your
[ __ ] life together dude you're a
child that shirt is for a fat kid yeah
Wow what's happening every podcast no it
doesn't brothers guys are completely out
of line now that was [ __ ]
that was insane that they live right
next door I mean what are the odds of
that
yeah oh it's happened before I mean just
I mean this is the first time they've
come over and started [ __ ] though yeah
we'll see ya getting man yeah I hope
it's the end yeah what's up guys sitting
here with this marijuana plant I think
also could be just a regular plant it
could be poison ivy brought about to
smoke myself in some itchy itchy just
watch another clip since you're already
here you know I'm saying